à la veille de la saint sylvestre une
quarantaine de joueurs s'affrontaient ce
week-end lors d'un tournoi amical de
futsal à la verrière l'occasion de
revenir sur le terrain de ses débuts
pour massadio haïdara aujourd'hui joueur
professionnel de l'as nancy lorraine
bah ça fait toujours plaisir moi quand
j'ai quand j'ai une coupure avec mon
club ou ou qu'on a un week-end
des livres j'essaie de rentrer le plus
souvent possible parce que ça fait du
bien de venir se ressourcer ou là où on
a grandi où on vit toujours
donc moi ça veut dire que quelqu'un ici
massadio haïdara chausse les crampons
pour la première fois avec le
football-club de la verrière
avant de rejoindre versailles puis lassé
boulogne billancourt
il intègre alors le centre de formation
de l'as nancy lorraine en 2008 à l'âge
de 15 ans malgré un début de carrière
prometteur le vernis roi n'oublie pas
ses racines n'oublie pas et voulait pas
d'où il vient
on sait qu'il a grandi ici que qui a
plein de jeunes qui aimeraient faire
comme lui il sait que qu'il a eu la
chance de pouvoir réussir dans ce
domaine c'est pas donné à tout le monde
ya beaucoup de ya beaucoup de
concurrence pour très peu de très peu de
postes
et c'est un exemple pour tous et pour
tous les jeunes qui jouent au foot mais
c'est à la grèce une compétition amicale
où il n'y a rien à gagner juste le
plaisir de jouer
mais le mental de compétiteur de
massadio haïdara ne disparaît jamais
complètement
enfin tournoi avec des amis d'enfance et
aider et d'autres amis que je connais
qui viennent pas dit si c'était un
tournoi amical mais c'est sûr que tout
le monde veut le gagner donc la
compétition j'ai fait bien avant de
reprendre la compétition
je me détends assez rapidement massadio
va retrouver les pelouses de ligue 1 ce
week end avant peut-être de partir vers
d'autres horizons européens mais sans
oublier ses amis d'enfance